Друзі Ну це ганьба ну Чим ви займаєтесь
і подивіться ви тому і не хочете щоб
Люди бачили що тут відбувається тому ви
ночами показуєте Верховну Раду бо
думаєте що це ну не може хоч менше людей
це побачать тому що ви плювати хотіли на
регламент тільки що питання справа не в
Мар'яні безуглій Справа в тому є рішення
комітету з нацбезпеки він щось пропонує
давайте розглядати Ні це нам не треба
але
ння призначити Ще свою людинку вже
призначили свою людинку на рахункову
тепер ще треба свою людинку призначити
на заступника голови фінансового
комітету ну це святе без цього ж ніяк це
головне питання в країні перший раз
зібралась Верховна Рада в цьому році
Подивіться якою ганьбою ви займаєтесь